hi I'm Erik Bosse and I just saw the
amazing guardians of the galaxy vol 2
and yeah this movie super fun and you
should go watch it right now if you
haven't already because I'm about to
talk about it all in this video and
there's a lot of stuff I love about this
movie the story the music the visuals
and possibly young Kurt Russell
Hasselhoff and I have a whole other
in-depth breakdown video coming out
about that stuff they should keep an eye
out for it but in the meantime as this
movie ended I began to wonder about one
thing in particular the way James Gunn
adapted the characters from the Marvel
Comics now I covered new characters like
ego the Living Planet and mantas and
Aisha in other trailer breakdowns
but in this video I'm going to talk
about the Ravagers so the ravager
funeral with colorful fireworks was such
a satisfying way to in this movie it was
really a star-studded event like whoa
sylvester stallone and bing rains and
michelle yeoh are here that was Miley
Cyrus technically she did mainframes
voice in the post-credits scene like
it's not like these guys are funeral
crashers who come in like a wrecking
ball and sorry
this event is a big deal and it points
to a whole world of characters that the
movie only really touches on and James
Gunn casting big names like Stallone as
the Ravagers means he considers them to
be important so let's look at who these
Ravagers are starting with Stallone's -
karo gourd now it looks like James Gunn
has heavily altered two cars character
from the comic but some of his backstory
might still come into the movies so
let's dig into it so the Karo gourd is
from an alternate universe in the Marvel
Comics timeline known as earth six nine
one the six nine one universe and in
that timeline he was the son of kids
miss Aisha no not this movie MCU version
of Aisha the comic version so there's a
big war that ends with the car as a baby
being raised alongside his stepsister
that he's also in love with Aleta
now Aleta is Michelle Yost character in
this movie but again same name probably
a different character anyway a lot of
crazy [ __ ] goes down that ends with the
car and Aleta merging their bodies to
form star hawk star hawk is a super
entity where the two of them trade off
control like when it's the car and he
can control lights and fly super fast he
also has advanced foresight of what will
happen which I'll talk about in a sec
where as elitist
Wurm is somewhat less powerful she can
manipulate light to make objects kind of
similar to Green Lantern's powers now if
the car also uses that foresight that I
mentioned a future events to manipulate
the timeline to be part of the original
guardians of the galaxy but then even
more crazy [ __ ] goes down ending with
Aleta going back in time to puts two
cards consciousness into himself as a
baby which is why he has that foresight
ability he basically relived his life
over and over again like this isn't that
help back to the future one bit just
free lives is life anyway all this is me
saying that there is so much cool and
same backstory force to Cara Nolita that
James Gunn could pull into Sylvester
Stallone and Michelle Yost versions of
the characters on screen in the
Cinematic Universe meanwhile in this
movie James Gunn has retcon these
characters as ravager captains within
the same Ravagers space pirate fleet
that Don dudes apart of a scene early in
the movie establishes the car as kind of
a father figure to yondu who rescued
yondu as an abandoned orphan and took
him under his wing teaching him the
Ravager waves but then yondu betrayed
him by dealing and trafficking children
Peter quill along with all the other
unfortunate offspring that ego left all
over the galaxy
now harming children is a huge violation
of Ravager code that's why later even
taser face refuses to kill baby Groot he
just stresses him like other Ravagers
and tries to make them into their mascot
so his history and trafficking children
has made gandu a hated outcast among the
other Ravagers that's why shekhar
angrily swears to him the colors of old
Lord will never blush over your grade by
the way he just notes alone and its head
is like I was doing Rambo and rocky
Ellen like talking about colors of
boards anyway that's why the fireworks
show at the end of movie is so important
rocket has told the car and the other
Ravagers about Nandu sacrifice and to
them that's the noble act worthy of
honoring neon do with the proper funeral
ritual now it's not clear whether James
Gunn has plans to go any further with
these two in the third guardians movie
but yeah he absolutely has some really
fun places to take them if he ever does
decide to do that but that also goes for
the other Ravagers who
up in the scene and in that post-credit
scene where's the car gets the old gang
back together to honor yondu's memory
and steal some [ __ ] so who are all these
guys one is Charlie 27 played by ving
rhames now in the Marvel Comics Charlie
27 was part of a version of the
guardians of the galaxy along with Yanbu
and Martin X I'll get to him in a second
but why is Charlie 27 so massive so he
was born to miners from Jupiter whose
bodies were genetically engineered to be
bigger and stronger and super dense to
withstand Jupiter's greater gravity
bigger and super dent kind of like this
further 27 also serves as a soldier and
he has a great military mind he's kind
of a strategy guy meanwhile in this
movie Charlie 27 is another ravager
leader who honors yondu and rejoins the
gang to honor his memory and this
Ravager is Martinek played by Michael
Rosenbaum aka Lex Luthor in Smallville
now in the comics mark next was born on
Pluto in his body is covered in these
crystal shards so that he's able to
withstand extreme temperatures I'm
guessing there's some history between
him and yondu as well given that angry
look that he gives me on to earlier in
the film there's also a mainframe voiced
by an uncredited Miley Cyrus in the
comics mainframe is an Android created
by Tony Stark and then in the Guardians
comics universe
he's a counterpart to vision who
protects Captain America shield but in
this movie mainframe appears to just be
a detached robotic head with Hannah
Montana's voice that's a super
interesting take on the character and
James Gunn has said that he had some fun
ideas for ways that he could use
mainframe in future films so we'll see
the other Ravager who shows up in the
toast credit scene is Krueger he
connected to the Doctor Strange comic
which is why he harnessed his mystical
energy in the same way that strange can
so Coover is a limb they live to be
super old and it's not totally clear how
old Krueger is but he later succeed
strange add see sorcerer supreme so
really this whole group at the end is
just kind of a motley crew of randos
that James Gunn is pulled into the
post-credits scene but many of them were
really part of one of the guardians
teams in the comics so it's cool to see
work them in like this and that brings
us to a super weird choice that James
Gunn made in this movie something he
promised he would never do in a
Guardians movie but he still changed his
mind about and I will talk about that in
a second but first
how quickly about our friends from Full
Sail University helped us with this
video so here at new rock stars were all
filmmakers and screenwriters editor's
general creative types and we'd love to
dive deep into the craft of filmmaking
on movies like guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 and full sales bachelor's degree
program immerses you in filmmaking from
every angle you get hands-on experience
while learning what it's like to work on
a film from start to finish giving you a
feel for the role each crew member plays
in production there's a digital
cinematography online degree program
that merges the artistic concepts of
traditional filmmaking with the
technical tools used in like
documentaries and commercials and web
videos like this one and if you already
have film experience and you just want
to take your skills to the next level
you can build a graduate level portfolio
while perfecting your technique in full
sales film graduate degree programs
especially here in Los Angeles I know a
ton of Full Sail grad and a lot of them
have gone on to work on great stuff that
we cover on this channel like Doctor
Strange Captain America Civil War The
Walking Dead lots of stuff and if you
want to find out more about these film
programs and how to get started visit
full sales edu slash new rockstars to
learn more okay let's get back to James
Gunn's super-surprising choice and
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 the
inclusion of taser face so in the movie
taser face is the ravager who stages a
mutiny because he's frustrated that
gandu is soft when it comes to the
Guardians and we confront us Thakkar but
in the comics taser face is a member of
the start it's an alien race who
accidentally received some of Tony
Stark's technology after he shipped it
off to earth by the way this is an
ultimate timeline of Erikson's don't
worry about it so the stark uses this
text to expedite the evolution of their
society and they deplete their planet's
natural resources and then move on to
conquer other world and teaser face was
their advance scout he later gets named
overkill and he's super obsessed with a
Benji and his friend who was apparently
killed by the Guardians but really other
than that
taser faces legacy is just this dumbass
low-level villain that James Gunn posted
a picture of on Facebook in 2012 calling
him the dumbest character of all time
promising that he would never feature
him in a guardian
movie but then gun explained that the
reason for his change of heart on taser
face was that he just needed a really
stupid ravager to briefly take over the
group specifically so that gun could
just make fun of his name and that is
why phaser faces primary function in the
movie is to pretty much just get mocked
by rocket the other Ravagers even one of
the sovereign laughing in his face right
before he died seriously this guy is
just an idiotic crowd [ __ ] whom no
one ever really takes seriously hey like
this and it actually worked this time
now with yondu's debt every ravager who
was ever part of his original crew has
now left the story but the exception is
cracklin who plays a much bigger role in
vol 2 like after briefly turning on
yondu he ends up redeeming himself
helping yondu rocket and Groot escape
this cell on the Ravinder ship and then
later helping all the Guardians lift off
egos planet as it explodes and of course
crag Lin shows up and that post-credits
scene fooling around with yondu's Yakka
arrow but i think the moment of Peter
Poole handing them the repaired arrow is
a key story beat so like the death of
yondu has made way for a lot of
characters to pick up his torch in
different ways like stack AR and the old
crew carry on his pirate ways Rockets is
now the resident outcasts without a real
family and quill is now filling this
role as the lawless gunslinger who now
understands the value of surrogate
father-son relationships but crag Lin is
the last remaining vestige of yondu's
life as a Ravager so it makes sense that
yondu's weapon symbolically passes down
to him kind of like Arthur's sword or
Luke's lightsaber it's a pretty cool and
pretty big responsibility for a
previously minor character I guess it
helps when the directors your brother
okay that covers the Ravagers and
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 in again
if you have questions about the other
characters go check out the other videos
I made about guardians so far and yeah
I'm working on another fuller more
in-depth breakdown of all the Easter
eggs and visuals and the music in the
film so be on the lookout for that and
of course if you like this video please
hit like and subscribe the new rock
stars you can also contribute to us on
patreon thank you so much all of our
current patrons especially Kenny Smith
you can hit me up on Twitter at EA box
with any thoughts you have about
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 or follow
new rocks
us on Twitter at new rockstars for
updates on our videos alright thanks for
watching bye
[Music]